yeah hello and welcome to this video
which covers the fifth round of this
year's time of co tournament it's a bit
of a late release but I opted for ya
quality rather than form yes business of
the release I couldn't release that a
couple of hours earlier like in the
middle of the night is that but I felt I
was just unfit to do a video so I'm
doing it right now when it's a bit later
but at least I now have a pretty good
idea I think what the games what
happened in the games and i think i can
tell you simply a better story now than
I could have done like 20 hours ago so
let's get going we'll start with
kayaking with white playing down audubon
and only go French defense I debarments
not a regular French defense player so
that certainly was a slight surprise and
yeah we get the assignments variation
which nowadays is probably the main line
of the French 93 is the most frequently
played move anyway and the winner of a
nowadays some isn't so much popular I
think it's probably believed to be a bit
too risky but okay we got this and the
Bishop e7 line here yeah this is a quite
popular line nowadays it was a big a bit
of a sideline for four years but now has
risen to absolute main line status yeah
black is firm not declaring his
intentions for the moment and in some
cases the I can even play later b6 to
allow to recapture on c5 with the pawn
it's a strategically quite rich move
Queen d2 plate by kayaking and a six
okay this is some one possibility black
can also tell forces a three votes plate
and this can be sometimes helpful to
fight for the dark square
antes y stakes are placed before castles
now why took 90 x + 3 f 2 this is
actually a well known position and was
played and none an important game for
this line the game between ruddy Makram
leg playing wide and the German Grand
Master gear Maya played in Baku last
year in the Chess Olympiad yeah Maya
back then played b6 after which Cromley
got a nice attacking game re-bond did
not play b6 but dropped back to d7 that
some the improvement I guess and yeah in
fact them I think it seems to be a
decent move certainly and the kayaking
very likely was not prepared for the
specific relegation for this game I
think very likely he had to have some
idea about it but it certainly was not
something that he expected to happen
yeah on that particular for that
particular game he played night to
deform Sally logical looking move takes
and now x.x that was the idea of that
early night retreat directly attacking
the center will f6 kayaking took and now
plays Bishop f6 and to be perfectly
honest I don't think that this is so
great um I was thinking and that's also
what the engine suggests that why
probably should carefully in this
position the idea is that if black now
wants to clarify matters in that way
what can actually play g3 or take and
play g3 and it's probably a little bit
better they're probably the immediate
g3s is correct this kind of structure
definitely gives widest I've advantage
those pawns are a little bit weak and
wide have some yeah the better chances
with this bishop that's more active than
the c8 bishop it's not a fatal for black
people to I definitely sped I think
leg will probably not take on before but
rather try something else like be five
it's an interesting position then I'm
not quite sure about the objective
Meredith it i think this is better than
what he did after the capture and queen
takes now therefore porn is immediately
under attack and probably kayaking
wanted to provoke what just what happens
now he played g3 and Ally one clay g5
note that that was all blissed out
public yeah he had all this and expected
problem yeah not so much ok I can for
sure yeah g5 a beautiful move right
cannot take an f2 is hanging and like
it's just trying to win the spot yeah it
doesn't matter that Jeep on is in front
of the king um it's really sets
difficult problems for why I think I'm
okay I can plate it okay at first and
castles long if it was taken and now
King to be one that also is to move that
the computer still approve proofs off
yeah to prove or something yep improve
them and but it is already a very
difficult position to handle and now
re-bond went every you are keeping his f
porn that's of course the most
principled choice not giving up on
getting back something and here is the
moment we're probably the fate of the
game is already decided in some way
because the move that still seems to
keep it somewhat balanced is not very
human if you ask me and was not played
by packing and it's the move look
deformed this in general activates the
hook on the first rank it allows this
and there seems to be a better choice
compared to what happened in the game
it's quite a quite difficult to analyze
this position as there are a couple of
possible
yes one idea could be 95 similar to the
games and then Luke f4 is the point
something like this and now the computer
suggests night a4 in order to go to c5
potentially back to by Bishop h3 and you
have some pressure against these six
this is definitely I'm definitely a
possibility however it does not strike
me as being particularly obvious in the
game kayaking played the move g-form
yeah and now 95 was played and it
doesn't look like White has enough here
for his materially we need the pawn down
and the f3 pawn is not something that
you can just ignore it ride g5 yeah
black black of course cannot take ever
look you want this business is going to
be far too dangerous as too much stuck
on the G file but just back to g7 and
white has trouble playing them yay
around the f3 porn it's just a
tremendously strong porn however I think
in the the biggest issue comes up now
after next move back Iacon he can still
continue with relatively normal playin
like h4 for example but now decided to
yeah give up another poem with g6 and
well it doesn't feel like he gets enough
now I did mine is two thumbs up and I
mean what doesn't really retain that
great compensation in the game black had
absolutely no problems in fending off
what yeah white ideas here on the G file
that important Bishop was taken care of
you know in black is covering g6
reliably with delicious
there was just one or two more funny
moments or funny as the wrong word but
aesthetically interesting moments a
rookie form and yeah now-now simple
moves like a five or King f7 do the
trick but Ali once found a nice work
rookie form there's maybe objectively
not even that brilliant but it's a
kitchen aesthetically quite pleasing to
smooth rookie for attacking deform yeah
kayaking took on g6 that doesn't work at
all the relatively best choice would
have been details before it still earn
is not great of course I complain a
gazelle Jay King jf seven and here black
is also winning the street XD for Bishop
e3 and so on but it's at least continues
the game and this just doesn't do
anything after Bishop takes me three
okay i can already resigned yes
something that group takes Queen takes
36 it's just materially hopeless like as
an exchange up and end the porn and
their free porn and so on it's just too
much plus note that this is a pretty
awkward diagonal so um wing surprising
Winnie frd bond against the yep the
challenger from the last World
Championships and kayaking was damn
close to getting them so surprising we
near by the Indian underdog in a very
convincing one I mean that just looked
like a very clean win but black yeah he
played an interesting opening and it
seems that he was much better prepared
and this was all part of the preparation
it seems so very good job Parvati bond
so and let's have a look what's the next
game to check um that's quite a couple
to check it yeah let's do let's do
Wesley so I'm
re Krishna which is a little bit of a
mystery to me this game to us so we have
a in English opening here liar
transposition steps now and d5 played
bass the Hari Krishna yeah and now I'm
then by far the most normal move with
c65 but Hari Krishna sorry but West they
so played played differently he played
the moon before and this is an
interesting reply to this the way Hari
Krishna reacts he gets into a pretty
awful position to be perfectly honest
and the position that is theoretically
well known probably he somehow was yeah
one of the well what is what is getting
into I mean it is known that Harry
Krishna is not focusing so much and
opening Siri compared to the other top
players but yeah the opening result that
he gets fairly bad so he now takes on
the form maybe you can improve here with
castles or other moves but this is what
he played and after plan a for check and
why it gets a really excellent position
yeah black replies with the normal move
9 p-2 d7 and castle so why does not
taking the sea for porn back I mean
currently if you would have done so that
b6 was just pretty awkward you don't
want to yeah I have ended like even more
or put the Queen on an awkward square
cancel this is the mr. battles castles
and now look T 1 why does again not
taking this pawn back but rather
improving in the center and increasing
the pressure yeah black plate 96 and
tween 83 is interesting that they both
spent some time there simply interesting
because this is the well-known game
actually
this is a well known sequence 26 takes
takes a4 a6 Bishop f4 and all this is
known this has been seen in the game
Kramnik with wide against a pony achi
from the Dortmund tournament 2015 so
it's a bit weird that black stumbled
into a well known position that is
basically unplayable for him I mean I've
gone through the moves and now we've
arrived at this position let's take
stock like of the pawn up but the
position is terrible really terrible why
does a lot more active with his pieces
if we check the bishops alone this is
great the activity is so enormous that
black is almost not not in a position
ever to keep the pond so he will lose
the pawn back and then we'll be in big
trouble in the original game crumbling
pneumonia chips nipple plate 98 and also
God's got pretty much destroyed in the
game here harikrishna trying to be five
note that he has spent had spent almost
all of his time up to this point and
what they sow also spend an hour so it
seems they both were not aware that they
had something on the boat that is
actually well known while so we have
played into a much better position so
it's okay yeah hurry crucian are getting
into something that is essentially yes I
mean this is a really terrible position
I'm a bit hesitant in saying it it's
almost losing but it is close to that
because you're lucky on you you lose
back the pond a key eludes back the pond
and you're in maining in a passive
situation porn sexy for a week and black
have some yeah very little to show for
that especially problematic is the very
strong bishop that keeps the keeps
everything frozen on the green side is
also why
now took this but here again is in huge
trouble 97's around here in the corner
and it's already almost impossible to do
to fend off and in fact he played Bishop
g4 and allowed 97 however it's a little
bit mysterious now the next move as so
rejected to play Knights in seven I
understand that this is not so easy to
calculate but still it looks a bit too
tempting i mean i was there i would have
been to attempt at the plane at c7 let's
have a look it was the strongest move 97
their only move that challenge is this
idea somewhat and certainly the one that
irritated the white player is now 9 2
g-3 looking at this yeah 93 funny funny
idea like takes takes this and well and
there are lots of white pieces hanging
the bishop on these six the knight on d4
yeah but yeah white has a have some
choice him most likely he will take on
the eggs Bishop takes push away 3 and
takes you there are a couple of other
lines but they all end up with wide
winning a teeny porn and having the more
active position like here where after
Bishop move move d 7 would be pretty
awful relatively rook the aid is
possible and then like trades rooks but
the bishop ending up on down is probably
lost as well so 97 would have been
pretty strong probably but there must
have been some yeah some line that so
did like objectively it is the best move
after luke t tool I'm sorry rook to hear
like it's getting a little bit yeah off
the hook is strong is still under
pressure but at least then
there is no direct loss around however
it is very difficult to play played
route to the 896 still problems there
with the with the pieces and I just
exist something that it's not at all
easy I mean it's a it is very tactical
now d 4 is attacked a lot a black so
Knight f3 it makes perfect sense takes
and takes here so black has given up an
exchange after all but it's got an
opponent for it and this is difficult to
play from like him after this Bishop
take C to a wide went 9 reform we should
be three Andrew P 3 and this kind of
position is purely technical it's just a
matter of correct calculation and here
black and missed the best move which
would be a bishop see to night before
what he played is probably losing the
game even though you have to be a little
bit sort of it cautious down what is
this position why does an exchange up
but it is difficult to wind a pawn is
somewhat weak and many endings would be
a draw even with the exchange of the
problem with nightly force that the
night years now coming back into the
game and the immediate ideas looks rupee
seven black is not attacking the ape on
all that quickly and there are chances
that white might win them in both pawns
in the long run this is extremely
difficult to to defend against also with
the look on the seventh-ranked black has
to reckon with white just attacking with
an idea let's say like neither 3g5
another right circumstances you're on 96
well plate and would be seven right
softwares not doing anything is it hey
what's going on oops a bit much so night
x + 5 loop t7 and now we see that the
water don't have the the best of
positions nice b3 and i tried this one
which is pretty hopeless but it's
already pretty much pretty much lost
this was the alternative but black's
pieces are completely uncoordinated and
an issue is also then why it is probably
going to get on the seventh and the tech
the f7 porn with the diet a little bit
later the a porn is not dangerous at all
it is also win this I think whatever
even easy my gestures to piss up they
continued for a little bit I think
you're just completing the time control
yeah I can still move 30 ATM yeah why it
is just a full crew peas up this is
games I think a little bit mysterious if
you consider nowadays level of prep her
accretion I just played into a line that
was close to impossible for him to play
it was just an extremely extremely bad
position that was eating it was also
very difficult to to hold there in a
practical game sometimes you have bad
position but at least it's easy to play
where this was bad and it was very tough
very tough to handle so bit of an
opening disaster so yeah what is so got
another wynant yeah after yet quilty
beat I'm kind of losing track the
opposite I know that yet is very lucky
win against report and then what was the
next one and very I think yeah now a
third win in a row can sorry Krishna
next game we check is more to check with
wide against lucrative a later of an
interesting game we got into and then
dooney's no kinks in unit yeah sorry
gotta kick Vinny
with c6 and asics bit of a rare system
but really it's not a regular Kings
Indian player nowadays but once in a
while he plays this opening I mean he
played it in his junior days at thought
so much nowadays because a very
interesting position and in fact I would
just go forward a little bit until we
have a more defined bone structure yeah
I think in this position water check has
gotten a good opening result he's got
the half-open see file he looks at this
slightly big pawn and it's not so easy
for black to change this pawn structure
favorably he has the awful to be file
but that doesn't do all that much that's
not taking over be eight but there's
nothing to attend so I think white is a
bit more comfortable in this position
all this feels fairly normal the night
has a good position on these recovering
b2 and looking at many critical squares
e6 9 p-1 interesting now this is opening
up the C file and my turn yeah
introduced various groupings for example
and I could come here c5 now fit villa
is not eager to keep the poem c64 any
longer however here after after this
sequence we see that white is putting
pressure against the c5 pawn and there
is no clear count of playful black I
think water check did a really good job
getting into this position he certainly
is a bit better and blacks position is
not very comfortable to play you don't
really see any activity and you see a
clear weakness here on black salt
now this was played and we get to a deep
position a little bit later the Queen
trade is certainly not something that
wide emergency and activators look and
even manages to win this week ish porn
everything looks yeah very smooth very
year logical for the first player look
to these six and now very interesting
phase of the game it's where I can move
the child control and black have a
threat look you want winning a piece and
how should white react to that and the
right move would have been King to f1
not a very difficult move to spot it's
just that the alternative also looks
very very okay but does not actually
work all that well however the reason
the reason and wives is is extremely
tough to see a little bit of a couple of
books later so king of one would have
been good we have we can have a look at
this move of course um yeah now and the
check ph doesn't make any sense and this
is hanging so black I mean if black goes
back there something like that is
attacking the night and this pin is
absolutely deadly you know the check is
this is useless only one so like yeah
seeing that this is good it's not
difficult seeing that the other move has
a problem however SDS is a different
matter you played rook see one back that
makes perfect sense now the rupee comes
back to comedy want and we attack with
removing the roof once you have the
attack tonight the very place correctly
it plays look to the seven doubling on
the default and attending the check
again damn tough now all of a sudden
from from a technical point of view note
that we
takes me to was also in the position
what the shakes head look everyone madam
proof that looks very intuitive but it
is the best move in the position
actually it's difficult to find
something better if you look at stuff
like and it's a there should be six
lengths will take and now I mean the
fact everything is hanging and black is
fine and then there are many tactics you
can look at your betrayal your self if
you like look at one is that is the best
movement things yeah and now the palm
got taken and 95 yeah and here this is a
relief amazing situation white is double
attacking b6 and the night at TechSoup
it looks pretty awful it looks like
black is losing material and when really
being in time trouble played 94 and
accepted the loss of the exchange
however it's interesting the computer
points out that black actually does not
earn have a lost position here he can
play just rook c6 where the said work
yeah it's a truly remarkable so there
are a couple of truly miracle tactics
that keep legs position together for
example if white takes with the bishop
there is Bishop 25 and all of a sudden
the rook is attacked it be six is
hanging quite quite a move loop the
eight and black has Ruby seven and
you're just playing a piece down but
everything works together there is
simply no way for white to keep the
material like this black takes on b5 and
covers the bishop it's a really a
miracle a miracle like defense loop
takes me six black can take and play
route p7 this is still better for white
if y can window is a
little bit in doubt I'm a little bit
skeptical there will be one by the way
there's 83 yeah this position might be
amazing sorry it's better for white how
much we mayn't would remain to be seen
for example this is a possibility where
white retains at all now it's at the
same but it's difficult oh it's much
more difficult to provide of course then
in the game after which it was just an
exchange of so this is how it continued
why do you want this point on a form
yeah they continued for a while but the
right position is technically winning it
here then really resigned so I'm an
interesting game I think feel a very
deserved victory for water shake who had
a great advantage and there was this one
miracle moment that when really could
have got it back into the game which
however is yeah it was difficult to do
in the first place and especially
difficult with no time on the clock
which is often a man various issue in
those tournaments see sometimes get some
position that I actually okay but they
need often be time to be played properly
and then them quite often you cannot
manage the problems so a good linear by
the Polish number one the final game I
want to check I'm also going to tell you
a bit about the other ones but I don't
know what the check here is the game
alien of Aronian so we have the leader
of the tournament alien of playing
Aronian why a transposition we got into
a Catalan opening with d take c form
this is the absolute main line of the
catalyst and the usual defense by our
own young Queens tools a six
and a for nowadays you don't see this
all that much anymore it seems that like
have decent resources there to equalize
f4 is a bit more testing Bishop d7 we
take and Bishop c6 this is how black
plays most of the time yeah with this
little zigzag maneuver the bishop gets
activated sometimes black moves
suspicious again that place e5 or in
some lines it takes on f3 and play c6
it's a it's very solid we should have
form this should be 6 and 3 c1 this has
been seen recently it's a fashionable
line takes takes 26 Quincy one again
this has been seen before and both
players plaintiffs rather quickly so I'm
what what to think about this position
in the Catalan quite often wide tries to
prove that his Bishop on g2 is the
stronger piece then the light squared
Bishop that black half oftentimes and
stuck on CH not doing all that much here
black has managed to get the bishop them
and with erroneous next move which is
the novelty technically speaking 55 and
he also potentially prepares see 725 or
just 96 to develop I think leg should be
quite okay here it's helpful that the
dark squared Bishop scottrade it because
they can look bit behind in terms of
space trade one pair of minus and makes
make sense I think this position is
probably roughly equal I think that can
be can be satisfied here Nancy 396 and
nitrile before the before square is weak
so use it quickly wanna obviously tried
to bring ya bring this newborn forward
to for so Aronian went back
liquids granel for the Queen and a five
yeah i think the position and certainly
should be equal ish however in the next
couple of moves white is slowly we are
slowly getting losing losing the control
of this i'm not sure about this 45 thing
actually to be honest the pond only five
can be an asset giving squares like d6
well yeah taking control over squares
like this but the point in itself can
become weak and black also has gotten
some a good square for his nights d 5b
5c six those all would be st. squares
for the ninth and nice definitely need
those um gathers outpost those positions
where they are very secure and black
certainly has costed those squares now
and the bishop on g2 is not doing all
that much actually have a bit of a
problem to pinpoint where exactly widest
losing the thread completely the engine
actually and dislikes after this sorry
look T 1 yeah black like as i mentioned
use this tool square and yeah the the
engine starts to completely dislike
White's position from here after the
next move which I agree with the next
the next move that alien of place is
indeed a bit weird to me office he plays
91 and I'm really not sure what this
move is doing I mean okay maybe simply
attacks the knife down 16 but it doesn't
and anything and design is not great
down the computers that young wants to
play Queen III just keeping keeping
everything I still rather be black hair
he's got the defiled
the Knights of strong I don't know I
don't even like this pushing the pawn to
your file I mean if you are honest III
with the pawn just compare this then if
this is equal this means d 4 is not weak
for example right here wyd really gets
into trouble I mean that's the immediate
threat which okay can be can be covered
but black is definitely for choice here
h5 is giving up even more ground and
here the Queen gets to g5 and now might
have some issues age five is used as
unprotected d5 is weak okay I hear he
already is in some trouble he took them
and now returned the Queen trying to
yeah keep things coordinated but yeah of
course like it's not trading that keeps
the Queen's Own and you'll see that
blacks position is just far more active
another night on f5 and the Queen og 5v5
remains weak and black also has
extremely nice control over the default
so it's definitely yeah quite
substantially better for him before the
true Queen a form takes rook takes and
and repeating all very normal Black is
certainly better as we mentioned but
it's not clear that he should win the
game quickly now however instead of a
normal move like that said a group c for
area not went whoopsie one and now
aronian has the move 94 and I mean a
night fork is nice to give but it is
specially nice to give if you can form
three pieces yeah I mean like every
piece that you can form and this
position is [ __ ] by the coming 92 so
it's just a lot of an exchange and
nothing nothing else I are not reduced
the exchange
and yeah and he resigned I believe could
also be that he lost some time judging
that the clock is on 000 but the
position is completely lost if you
reside are not some time doesn't matter
all that much it is a losing position a
bitter will be it gleam if you ask me I
am not quite certain what happened also
the end of it is a bit uncharacteristic
for alien or farming either good
defender normally and somehow in this
game never really got its got got
something maybe he didn't know how to
play play it correctly from here now
yeah it's certainly equal ish position
and maybe he was too ambitious with this
a 45 business I think it rather hurt him
that that then helped somehow this is
killing me as I said like tons of good
squares for the knives and the bishop on
g2 doesn't do all that much it is
certainly not terrible for white but I
feel like the issues began began at this
point so we had for decisive games and a
lien off was stopped by his winning
streak stopped him by Aronian we had
some other games that ended in a draw
and were actually quite interesting the
game ye during in particular was quite
nice but I want to limit the video to
some reasonable length depth on yet she
Carlton wasn't all that interesting it
was a very yeah very safe opening up by
by both players and it wasn't all that
thrilling and we had a draicon report um
yeah again that will also wasn't wasn't
all that exciting there were some
interesting points I have to say and
raking was better and mainly could have
done something but ultimately report
defended this so we had a nice round
around five with for decisive games and
yeah so taking the leader with plus free
after
win so yeah i'll be back very shortly
with round six coverage let's play today
thanks for watching